[Music]
godzilla will come for him
there can't be two alpha titans who
bounce the hoop
kong bows to no one
there is something provoking into war
the myths are real
[Music]
they have an ancient rivalry
[Applause]
there was a war
and they're the last one standing
[Music]
did the monkey just talk we need kong
the world needs him godzilla will
comfort him
that would be a death sentence
they have an ancient rivalry godzilla
will come for him
we need kong the world needs him
kong may be our only hope
i know gia is only a child she's the
only one he'll communicate with
and we need kong
here we go this won't end until one of
them submits
are you sure the monkey's going to
survive this it's unless i'd worry about
oh my god this is so massive
[Music]
we need cop the world needs him
she's the only one he'll communicate
with
it's godzilla
[Music]
[Music]
this is our only chance
we have to take
we need kong the world needs him
to stop what's coming
in this child she's the only one he'll
communicate with
i knew that they had a bond she had
nowhere to go so
i made a promise to protect her
and i think that in some way khan did
the same
[Music]
[Music]
it's godzilla
[Music]
these are dangerous times godzilla's out
there and he's hurting people and we
don't know why
there's something provoking him that
we're not seeing here by the same
opinion
the myths are real there was a war
and they're the last ones standing for
greatness
kong bows to no one
you